please welcome music superstar billy
eilish
yo so i started watching that movie
never rarely sometimes always
and i wanted to finish it so bad dude
but then the girl in there pierced her
own nose so that gave me an idea and i
tried to pierce my own nose and bro
it did not go so well because like i was
actually eating a bean and no cheese
burrito from taco bell in one hand
and trying to pierce my nose with the
other and guess what
i pierced my burrito
and it looked pretty sick like it should
be in a museum bro like that's art
luckily my brother phineas sees the art
and everything and he was like yo
billy we gotta write a song about this
so we did
i took out my invisalign and i sang the
song
don't you know i pierced my burrito
i never thought i'd pierce
my burrito i rarely pierce my nose while
eating but sometimes i've been burritos
what you're feeling
i always get chips and walk if i'm
feeling crazy
i could like say i never rarely
sometimes always
what's that phineas dude we just want a
grammy for that song
i'm a genius all right bye
you